Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
So, St. Pauli hat 2-1 gewonnen und Union hat 3-1 gewonnen.
Das war es dann auch schon mit den guten Nachrichten.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 539 vom 16.
Dezember 2025 und ihr seht, wir wissen einfach, wo man hingucken muss,
wenn man die Laune heben will.
Ja, da bleibt derzeit eigentlich nur Fußball, nicht unbedingt jetzt an jedem
Wochenende, aber diesmal hat es gerade mal so gepasst.
Das war ein gutes Wochenende für den deutschen Fußball.
Ja, und ansonsten haben wir auch noch Feedback bekommen, das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Immer eine gute Nachricht. Ja, also vielleicht ist es auch nicht ganz so schwarzmalerisch,
aber ansonsten muss ich sagen.
Ich habe gestern auch zum Beispiel Plätzchen, das war auch schön.
Hast du gebacken?
Nee, habe ich geschonken gekrochen.
Geschonken gekrochen bekommen? Hast du auch schon mal Plätzchen selber gemacht?
Nee.
Bist du nicht so ein Backmensch?
Also als Kind habe ich das mal mit meiner Mama gemacht.
Ah, aber hat nicht zur Verstätigung gebracht.
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal probieren.
Ach, ich finde das ist sicherlich ganz nett, aber würde ich auch gerne mal machen,
habe ich aber keine Zeit für.
Tja, schwierig.
Pizza kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Außer bei uns gibt es die im Supermarkt übrigens Plätzchen.
Wirklich?
Ja, so ab September. Muss man gar nicht selber machen.
Na sowas.
Ja, also mit Weihnachtsromantik ist bei uns ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, da sind wir jetzt nicht so die Experten für.
Gucken wir mal, wie wir uns in den anderen Bereichen so schlagen.
Gucken wir mal aufs Feedback. Gab es welches? Ja.
Und zwar hat sich André geäußert zum Thema Radio Dreieckland,
was wir hier nochmal verkündet haben.
Er schreibt, bei der links unten Dreieckland Geschichte fehlen zwei Punkte.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft hat per Polizei Leute durchsucht, die Mitglieder der
verbotenen Vereinigung hätten sein sollen.
Bei einer beschuldigten Person gab es auch mal einen Bericht,
dass die Polizei drohte, das verschlüsselte Mac-Gerät zu zerstören,
wenn die Person das Passwort nicht rausgeben würde.
Jedenfalls hat dann die Staatsanwaltschaft vermeldet, dass sie niemanden der
Mitgliedschaft bezichtigen würde und die Verfahren einstellen müsste.
Darüber hat dann der Bericht bei Radio Dreieckland berichtet,
inklusive Link auf die statische Seite von links unten in die Media Satzzeichen.org.
Und zur Durchsuchung beim Journalisten, die wohl hätte den Computer liefern
sollen, über den, der seinen Artikel
veröffentlicht hat, hat sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht nun geäußert.
Ich hätte ja eine Idee wo man verfassungswidrig agierende Organisationen suchen
könnte, aber vielleicht nicht gerade als Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe.
Ich finde es auch geil Polizei droht mit der Vernichtung von Beweismitteln.
Und dann auch noch Max also da hört auch wirklich der Spaß auf weiß wie teuer
sowas ist schlimm Hater alles Hater.
Dann gab es Anmerkungen zu unserem Glasfaser-Thema.
Wir erinnern uns, keiner will Glasfaser kaufen, warum nur?
Dazu merkt Fred an.
Das erste DSL, an das ich mich erinnern kann, war damals 768 Kilobit pro Sekunde
oder 384 Kilobit pro Sekunde, wenn man zu weit vom DSLAM entfernt wohnte.
Damit fing das nämlich tatsächlich mal an, ich erinnere mich auch.
Letzteres natürlich zum vollen Preis.
Ein Megabit pro Sekunde kam später, dicht gefolgt von zwei Megabit pro Sekunde
und das war ja schon eine Offenbarung. Inzwischen habe ich 16 Megabit,
das kleinste Angebot hier vor Ort.
Die Telekommunikationskonzerne bekommen von mir nur das Minimum.
Man muss die ja für das Kasperle-Theater nicht noch belohnen.
Was den Glasfaserausbau angeht, läuft hier ein Anbieter rum und macht Vorverträge.
Die Beträge, die darauf genannt werden, sind nicht fest, sodass auf der letzten
Infoveranstaltung des Anbieters verkündet wurde,
dass aus den angegebenen 700 Euro vermutlich 2000 oder mehr werden Und zwar
egal, ob man, wie ich, schon selbst Rohre gelegt hat oder nicht.
Also ist ein Drittel der Leute hier im Ort von ihrem Vorvertrag zurückgetreten, ich auch.
Dass wir kein vernünftiges Internet haben, ist nicht Schuld der Bürger oder
Verbraucher und auch nicht in deren Verantwortung.
Wir haben auch Großindustrie hier im Ort und die haben ordentliche Glasfaser.
An den Baukosten hatte sich die Gemeinde oder das Land beteiligt.
Ja, nope, einfach nope. Ja, das ist so das Problem.
Das ist alles sehr ungleich verteilt. Die Leute sollen an den Kosten beteiligt werden,
weil es da einfach keine richtigen Regularien und Vorgehensweisen gibt,
wie das gemacht wird und an der Stelle kann man sich eigentlich auch nur wiederholen,
dass das Land diesen Kerninfrastrukturausbau nicht als seine Aufgabe sieht,
ist eigentlich der große Fail.
Dann gibt es noch Anmerkungen von Georg zum Thema Support der Meta-Ebene.
Was für ein schönes Thema.
Witzig, bei der Echtzeitüberweisung mit Empfängerüberprüfung spoilert das Bankinterface
immer zusätzliche Informationen über den Empfänger, die in diesem Fall aber
ohnehin bekannt sind, nur nicht auf der Überweisungsseite stehen.
Wer weiß, ob sich dahinter nicht auch irgendwo eine Sicherheitslücke versteckt,
sodass man mal eben alle Bankkontoinhaber bestimmter Banken durch raufzählende
Kontonummer herausbekommen kann.
Wenn sie wie Meta das Rate Limiting vergessen haben, könnten da ganze Datensätze rausfallen.
Ach ja, Spende ist raus. Vielen Dank.
Ja, hast du das mitbekommen? Es gab ja eine Regeländerung jetzt irgendwann in diesem Dezember.
Müssen die Banken genauer überprüfen, wer als Empfänger einer Überweisung angegeben ist.
Ich dachte, das müssten die eh.
Das mussten die schon eh immer, aber jetzt muss es noch mal enger,
ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Änderung genau formuliert ist,
aber jetzt sind sie da etwas weiter hinterher.
Ich habe auch einen Brief bekommen von meiner Bank, wo es so drinsteht mit,
das sind die fünf, sechs Varianten von Namen, die wir als valide anerkennen.
Aber viele, die mir irgendwas überwiesen haben, mussten dann noch meinen zweiten
Vornamen noch mit angeben, beziehungsweise haben den von der Bank einfach so
als Vorschlag bekommen. Meinten sie nicht das?
Theo der Prinz, der tapfere Hüter. Was ist das? Hüter des Hauses?
Hüter der Flamme des Herzens.
Achso, ja, sorry.
Genau, da passe ich gut drauf auf. Und ja, wurde auch schon kritisiert,
dass das ja dann sozusagen die Möglichkeit ist, dann so Realnamen herauszubekommen,
die vielleicht nicht unbedingt so öffentlich sein sollten.
Anyway, vielen Dank für deine Unterstützung, Georg.
Und der Punkt ist, dass man diese Abfrage machen kann, ohne etwas tatsächlich
überweisen zu müssen, oder?
Der Punkt ist, dass man halt erst überweisen kann, wenn man den Namen richtig
weiß, aber dann die Bank selber einem Hintz gibt, was denn der richtige Name sein könnte.
Und damit sozusagen diese Information rausgibt. Und es ist so ein bisschen,
ich weiß nicht, es ist so ein bisschen Sicherheitstheater an der Stelle.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das jetzt wirklich dazu führen wird,
dass das Fraud-System da besser funktioniert.
Wie die diesen Check machen, der muss halt auf eine Weise irgendwie sehr fuzzy sein.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel heute noch meine Merge-Order zum 39C3 bezahlt.
Und dann als Empfängerin muss ich ja dann die Chaos Computer Club,
Veranstaltungsgesellschaft MBH angeben und da zittern natürlich auch die Hände,
dass man sich vertippt und das Geld nicht ankommt und dann kommt immer so dieser
ja ja, wir haben das jetzt verifiziert, weil da natürlich sehr viele,
Tippfehler oder eben fehlt man, Mittelnahme ist einer dabei und so,
es gibt natürlich, also ich würde vermuten, dass sie halt recht schlechte oder
nicht so wirklich bei einem Close-Match muss er übermittelt werden.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt was völlig Falsches sagst, sagt er einfach nur,
stimmt nicht. Und wenn du nah genug dran bist, dann sagt er dir, naja, hier,
Hüter der Flamme des Herzens. Und ich habe mir das jetzt noch nicht genau darüber
nachgedacht, wie man das...
Wie man das richtig machen würde, also wie man das Privacy-Aware machen würde,
aber hier gibt es auch einen Artikel von Netzpolitik.org, wo wir so ein bisschen
vor allem sagen, es wird halt unterschiedlich gemacht, weil klar,
der antwortenden Bank wird dringend empfohlen,
in der Close-Match-Antwort Datenminimierung anzuwenden.
Und nur die Namensinformationen zur Verfügung zu stellen, die in der Anfrage genannt wurden.
Dringende Empfehlungen heißt, bastelt jeder was eigenes und dann hast du halt
unterschiedliche, also für sowas schreibt man dann halt Standards.
Also wie gut so Annahmen über Namensstruktur funktionieren, kennt ja eigentlich
jeder, der schon mal in irgendein Webformular in einem amerikanischen was eingegeben hat.
Man kennt das ja auch von Hausanschriften, Formatierung und so weiter.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, was das jetzt mit arabischstämmigen Namen macht.
Zum Beispiel Namen aus einem Bereich der Welt, die einfach eine andere Logik haben.
Allein Spanien da mit diesem ganzen Vornamens-Nachnamenswirrwarr und die Mutter
und der Vater und was da nicht alles noch mit drin ist.
Die kriegen kein Geld von mir deswegen.
Gibt nichts mehr für euch.
Der kann man ja gar nicht überweisen euch da.
So ein Schnickschnack. Die Rechnung konnte nicht bezahlt werden wegen komischem Namen.
Ja, nee, da auch irgendwie Maria, Sanchez, Luis und irgendein komischer...
Nee, nee, nee. Da überweisen wir kein Geld hin.
Nix da. Spanien kriegt nix.
Ja, kriege ich halt leider dann auch niemals Tickets für Barca, aber...
Das ist eh nicht so geil. Geh lieber zur Union.
Ja, die also ich bin mal ich weiß nicht, also man muss noch gucken,
ich hab das jetzt so mal zur Kenntnis genommen ich hab jetzt meine,
Kontonummer eh immer als etwas genommen jetzt ist es auch so,
dass ich jetzt quasi nicht meinen Realnamen verberge,
und auch nicht unbedingt die Kontonummer, insofern müsste man nochmal sich genauer
über die wirklichen Abuse-Szenarien Gedanken machen,
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon
mal, ich bin mir sicher, dass es Menschen gibt, die das ungerne haben.
Menschen, die vielleicht ihren Namen geändert haben oder dabei sind, die zu ändern.
Oder zum Beispiel happy sind, sich nur an einen Nachnamen überweisen zu lassen
und nicht notwendigerweise an alle 27 Vornamen.
Ähm...
Dann hier unter Selbstbestimmungsgesetz eine Namensänderung,
das ist natürlich da auch irgendwie unschön.
Ärgerlich sowas nicht ordentlich zu regeln.
Es ist ja generell löblich. Ich meine, was ja hier verhindert werden soll,
ist, dass Leuten falsche IBANs untergejubelt
werden in irgendeinem Scamming-Kontext und die dann im Glauben,
Person X etwas zu überweisen, ist letzten Endes Person Y überweisen.
Nur, dass du irgendwelche Zahlendreher drin hast. Und das soll natürlich dann
helfen, weil das dann quasi die zweite Information ist mit hier,
das ist halt die Person, die ich eigentlich meinte.
Aber weil Leute eben manchmal einfach die Namen dann nicht richtig schreiben,
nicht ausschreiben oder falsch schreiben,
will man eben jetzt auch nicht verhindern, dass jetzt alle möglichen Überweisungen auf einmal scheitern.
Du hast José María Sanchez Luis de la Corne del Sole falsch geschrieben. Viel Spaß.
Genau. Und deswegen halt dieser Mechanismus.
Also ich will da jetzt nicht drauf einhauen, es ist halt einfach ein generelles Problem.
Bei einer normalen Überweisung macht es die Bank halt im Backend,
bei einer Echtzeitüberweisung muss sie das eben,
den Check ja auch in Realtime machen und dir dann im Zweifelsfall,
damit du nicht in der Frustration mündest,
eben helfen oder annähernd großzügig auslegen, dass du dich vielleicht vertippt hast, ja.
Auf jeden Fall, also Funktionalität schön, nicht so schön,
wenn es halt uneinheitlich irgendwie umgesetzt wird und da halt keine,
nicht einfach mal ein klares Verfahren gemacht wird, sondern so gesagt wird,
jede Bank kann mal irgendwie so und dringend empfohlen und hast alles nicht gesehen.
Genau, mach doch einfach mal richtig.
Genau, mach doch mal was ordentlich.
So, also wer Tims, komplette Reihe an Vornamen haben will, muss jetzt eine Echtzeitüberweisung,
Ich hab ja jetzt nur noch einen weiteren Vornamen Wer die meisten Versuche hat
mit Geldüberweisen alle Vornamen Dadurch.
Dass ich Deutscher geworden bin, ist es ja ein bisschen einfacher geworden,
da muss ich ja einen Vornamen streichen Ja.
Aha, dann ist das Spiel jetzt den Herr Ross.
Aber nicht in Überweisung schreiben.
Okay, wir wollen noch mal kurz ein bisschen zusammenfassen.
Dieses Jahr immer wieder viel Thema gewesen, die Chatkontrolle.
Und was ist da jetzt der genaue Stand?
Wir haben es in der letzten Sendung schon einmal zusammengefasst, Widerstand war,
aber jetzt gibt es bei Netzpolitik.org erarbeitet von André Meister,
Anna Biselli und Markus Reuter so eine FAQ, wo das alles noch mal genau erklärt ist. Wie war das?
Vorschlag kam von der Kommission. Die Kommission hatte auf jeden Fall die schlechteste
Idee mit KI-Scanning von Text und Bild und direkten Ausleiten an die,
zentrale Ermittlungsbehörde auf dem Client sogar dann eben durch AI die Erkennung
potenziell neuer Materialien, das hätte eben,
geheißen, dass jede Nachricht ein- und ausgehend irgendwie von der KI gelesen
und potenziell an die Bullen ausgeleitet wird.
Ein bisschen könnte man als so eine Maximalposition sehen.
Dann hat das Parlament schon im November 23 gesagt, das finden wir nicht so
gut, also anlasslose Aufdeckungsanordnungen gefallen uns nicht,
die verschlüsselte Kommunikation soll nicht gescannt werden dürfen,
wir wollen auch die Arten des Materials einschränken, nach denen gesucht werden darf,
also zum Beispiel wollten sie nicht diese Grooming-Erkennung,
also Anbahnungsversuche von erwachsenen Kindern wollten sie ähm,
Also wollten sie nicht. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, Altersüberprüfung,
was eben auch ein Problem ist, weil die Altersüberprüfung eben entweder mit
dem Ausweis oder anhand biometrischer Merkmale stattfindet.
Da haben sie gesagt, das ist freiwillig außer bei Pornoseiten. Da wollen sie das.
Und das war dann die Position des Parlaments. Und dann hat der Rat sich Ewigkeiten gezankt.
Worauf sind sie jetzt gekommen?
Sie haben gesagt...
Es gibt keine Verpflichtung zum Scanning.
Also die gesamte Teilaufdeckungspflichten hat der Rat gestrichen.
Aber freiwillig soll es gehen.
Sie sagen, das soll aber auch nicht verboten sein. Wir erinnern uns,
die E-Privacy-Richtlinie von 2002 verbietet das nämlich.
Und die haben ja immer wieder die Ausnahmen gemacht.
Und sie sagen, das betrifft dann nicht nur Bilder und URLs, sondern eben auch Texte und Videos.
Andere Teile, wie zum Beispiel hier Alterskontrolle, bleiben so.
Und das ist jetzt die Position des Rats. Jetzt gehen die drei in den Trilog
und werden sich dann eben einigen müssen.
Ja, diese Positionen, die die jetzt haben, sind jeweils nur das Verhandlungsmandat,
wenn es dann in den Trilog geht.
Dann wird also sich immer noch entscheiden, wird es verpflichtendes,
freiwilliges oder eben anlassbezogenes Scannen, Anordnungen geben,
wenn es eine Freiwillige geben sollte,
wie wird es positioniert, wie viel Druck oder Anreize gibt es, das dann auch zu tun.
Bekommt man irgendeinen Vorteil, wenn man das macht? In welchem Rahmen?
Was wird man suchen dürfen, was nicht?
Gilt eine Ausnahme für verschlüsselte Kommunikation? All diese Fragen werden
dann eben im Trilog qualifiziert.
Entscheidend ist, dass es jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich zwei teilnehmende Parteien
gibt, die in weiten Teilen dagegen sind, ja.
Da muss man also nochmal schauen, wie sich, wie dann der Trilog verläuft.
Also ein wirklich fürchterlicher Ablauf, so eine EU-Gesetzgebung.
So ein absolutes Trainwreck, weißt du, wo du so über Jahre dieses Geschehen
verfolgen musst. Das ist wunderschön.
Da kann man ein ganzes Podcast-Imperium drauf gründen, nur darüber regelmäßig zu reden.
Tolle Idee.
Wenn aber die EU dann irgendwann mal fertig ist mit sowas und hat dann zum Beispiel
ein Digital Markets oder ein Digital Services Act, dann stellt sich ja die Frage,
kommt die denn auch zur Anwendung?
Könnte fast so sein jetzt.
Könnte fast so sein, ja.
Also 23 ging ja Digital Services Act in Kraft,
und hat den sozialen Netzwerken vorgeschrieben, bestimmte Regeln,
die denn doch einzuhalten seien und überraschenderweise gab es welche,
die die nicht eingehalten haben.
Was?
Also Skandal, ja.
Lass mich das sofort twittern.
Das heißt nicht twittern, das heißt jetzt x-en.
Okay.
Und jetzt, zwei Jahre später,
wurde dann auch die erste Strafe auf Basis von Verstößen gegen den Digital Services
Act ausgesprochen durch die EU-Kommission.
Und zwar betriffte es wenig überraschend den ehemaligen Twitter-Dienst X von Herrn Musk.
Und die EU wirft dem Netzwerk vor, einerseits Täuschung von Nutzern,
das ist diese Geschichte mit dem blauen Haken,
die ja früher mal für eine Verifikation der Person steht,
also quasi insinuiert, dass das Netzwerk mal sichergestellt hat und weiß, wer diese Person ist.
Ich hatte ja auch mal so einen Haken.
Ist der wieder weggegangen?
Habe ich gar nicht geguckt Gute Frage Du hast den einfach so bekommen Ich habe
den damals einfach so bekommen Und ich kann dir nicht sagen Wer Das gemacht hat,
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß gar nicht, wenn ich selber,
also ich glaube nicht, dass ich den noch habe, weil derzeit bedeutet das ja
nicht nur, dass man bezahlt hat.
Das war ja die Änderung oder eine der Änderungen, die dann Elon Musk relativ schnell umgesetzt hat.
In anderen Worten, man konnte sich den erkaufen und weil das halt eine Täuschung
von Nutzern ist, nachvollziehbarerweise, gibt es dafür 45 Millionen Euro Strafe.
Außerdem wird dem Netzwerk mangelnde Transparenz bei Werbung vorgeworfen,
also dass man nicht weiß, wer dahinter steht.
Da sind mir jetzt die konkreten Regeln gerade nicht innerlich,
aber das war auch nochmal 35 Millionen Euro wert.
Und es gäbe auch keinen ausreichenden Zugang für Forschung.
Das ist ja Teil des Digital Services Act, dass man in den Netzen vorgeschrieben
hat, ihr müsst ermöglichen, dass Forscher das Innenleben eures Netzwerks analysieren können.
Damit man eben Belege dafür hat, was da vor sich geht oder weniger Belege,
aber dass man sozusagen das analysieren kann, dass man eben an der Stelle auch.
Wissenschaft betreiben kann,
einfach um einen gewissen Erkenntnisgewinn für die Öffentlichkeit zu haben.
Auch das ist nicht in ausreichendem Maße erfolgt und hat nochmal weitere 40 Millionen Euro.
Macht summarum 120 Millionen Euro.
Ja gut, da muss man die EU jetzt zumachen.
Also das geht ja wohl jetzt nicht. Also sorry, das sollte ja wohl allen klar
sein. Wenn die EU gegen X verstößt.
Dann ist die EU ungültig. Genau, EU ungültig.
Also eigentlich sollte jetzt X erstmal innerhalb von 90 Tagen Abhilfe schaffen.
Das heißt, bis Mitte Januar Zeit darauf einzugehen.
Also die Strafe gilt glaube ich auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn es innerhalb von 90
Tagen nicht behoben wird, dann können eben weitere Strafen herangezogen werden
und Elon Musk war natürlich außer sich und in seiner bekannten,
abwägenden und diplomatisch vorgetragenen Reaktion hat er dann erstmal der EU ihren Account,
Und also den Status ihres Accounts, also nicht den Accounts selber gesperrt,
sondern sozusagen diesen Ad-Status.
Also man kann halt auf X, sein Account kann in so einen, ich weiß nicht wie
der Modus genau heißt, aber dann hat man eben Zugriff auf Analytics und kann
eben dann auch in dem Rahmen Werbung schalten, wenn man denn das will.
Das hat die EU laut eigener Aussage schon seit langem nicht mehr getan.
Also die EU-Kommission hat kein Geld ausgegeben, um Werbung auf X zu schalten.
Und hat aber nach eigener Aussage sehr wohl diese Analytics,
die ihnen dann präsentiert würden, was halt so Reach und so weiter von deinen
Tweets liefert, genutzt.
Das können sie jetzt aber nicht mehr, weil eben mit dieser Sperrung,
die jetzt X einfach eigenmächtig vorgenommen hat, diese Möglichkeit dann nicht mehr bietet.
Und es gab natürlich dann auch einen Grund, einen vorgeschobenen.
Ja, also der Technikchef meinte dann so, ja, hier die EU hätte irgendwie ein
Exploit in unserem Ad-Composer ausgenutzt, um irgendwie, dass Leute glauben,
dass ein Link im Video sei oder so. Ich weiß nicht, völlig absurd.
Ja, also sie haben tatsächlich wohl irgendwie...
Also quasi, also das könnte man, glaube ich, tatsächlich, also da bin ich mir
sicher, dass das gegen irgendetwas verstößt.
Wir haben quasi ein Bild gemacht, was aussieht, als würde man da jetzt ein Video
sehen, aber dadurch hat man die Seite besucht.
Achso, ja, okay. Wahnsinn. Also ein unglaublicher Verstoß, der wirklich...
Etwas, was natürlich irgendwie Elon Musk niemals tun würde. Also das, aber gut.
Vor allem nichts, was man nicht einfach auch mal durch so eine kleine Mail mit
hey Leute, mach das mal nicht aus der Welt schaffen könnte.
Also er hat natürlich jetzt suchen lassen.
Also das war einfach dann so ein Rage-Modus und gab natürlich dann auch gleich
die passende Reaktion von anderen Torfköppen.
Also der US-Außenminister Marco Rubio sprach dann gleich von einem Angriff auf
die amerikanischen Menschen.
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, dass übrigens, ich denke, dass er gesagt hat, American people.
Und das ist dann nicht die Menschen, sondern das amerikanische Volk.
Ja, das Volk, die Menschen, was auch immer. Also ist ja letztlich das Gleiche.
Dann auch Ted Cruz, weiß ich auch, da nicht zu schade gleich irgendwie Sanktionen zu fordern.
Also das ist ja so ein neues Ding, dass jetzt die USA so voll anti-Europa ist
und man soll ja mal die EU auflösen, das hat Elon Musk natürlich dann auch gleich gefordert,
weil, wo gucken wir denn da hin mit der EU, das ist ja sozusagen gerade ihr
Fiebertraum, sozusagen dieses EU-Bündnis sich auflösen zu lassen,
damit sie dann irgendwie die Staaten einzeln auf links drehen können.
Naja, also ist es weiterhin alles ein Trauerspiel mit diesem Netzwerk und es
ist wirklich schade, dass es immer noch so viel Relevanz hat.
Allerdings haben sie auch mal ein ganz brauchbares Feature eingebaut und ich
frage mich immer, warum sie sowas überhaupt einbauen, weil es so ein bisschen
ihren eigenen Interessen oder den Interessen von Elon Musk doch zuwiderläuft.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt es jetzt ein Location-Feature in X.
Und zwar, wenn man auf das Profil eines Accounts geht, dann hat man da nochmal
so ein Kontextmenü und da gibt es dann wiederum den Unterpunkt about this account
oder über diesen Account auf Deutsch.
Und wenn man da drauf geht, dann sieht man nochmal so ein paar Details.
Unter anderem den Ort, von dem aus normalerweise gepostet wird.
Das heißt, sie analysieren da einfach mal, Die Absenderadressen von den Tweets
und schreiben das dann hin.
Und es wird auch noch vermerkt, wenn der Account sich umbenannt hat. Man kann das ja machen.
Also eigentlich keine so schlechten Features.
Nee, tatsächlich keine schlechten Features. Und dann haben auch gleich mal ein
paar Leute nachgeguckt und festgestellt,
dass zum Beispiel eine ganze Reihe von MAGA-freundlichen Accounts auf X nicht unbedingt jetzt so,
aus den USA zu stammen scheinen.
Ach was.
Dass sie also teilweise aus Russland, aus Thailand, aus Nigeria und solchen Orten posten.
Und Indien, also hier, was weiß ich, Marga Nation X mit 400.000 Followern,
kommt irgendwo aus Osteuropa.
Eine Marga Nadine, die wohl auch recht bekannt ist, Postet aus Marokko,
ein America First Account, der hat nicht so viele Follower, kommt aus Bangladesch und so weiter.
Das war schon ganz insightvoll und scheint auch ein gängiges Thema zu sein.
Ich meine, nichts, was uns jetzt sonderlich überraschen sollte, es ist ja wohl bekannt,
dass es eben genug Möglichkeiten gibt, irgendwelche Massenaccounts sich in anderen Ländern,
wo die Arbeitsstunde von Personen nicht so viel kostet.
Pimpen zu lassen und posten zu lassen, was auch immer, um da entsprechende Propaganda
zu betreiben. Aber es ist natürlich dann auch immer ganz interessant,
das dann auch mal konkret festzustellen.
Ähnliches wurde von der BBC zum Beispiel auch von schottischen patriotischen
Accounts, die also jetzt für die Loslösung von Schottland aus UK eintreten.
Also das ist halt so ein wiederkehrendes Theme, also,
Destabilisierung über soziale Netzwerke, in dem halt bestimmte politische Positionen
gepusht werden von angeblichen Personen,
die ja, Teil der Sache sein sollten, die aber offensichtlich einfach von irgendwelchen
Trollen around the world betrieben werden und das ist ja.
Nur noch ergänzend, das Problem ist nicht,
Also das Problem ist natürlich auch, dass es getan wird, ja.
Das Problem ist aber insbesondere, dass es natürlich von Twitter alles andere
als irgendwie limitiert wird.
Oder von X. Ich glaube,
wenn man sich da die alten Folgen anhört, wie ich jetzt auch zum Beispiel über
den Kauf von Twitter nachgedacht habe,
Da habe ich offenbar sowohl den Wahnsinn von Elon Musk als auch seinen Reichtum massiv unterschätzt,
aber auch die Möglichkeiten,
wie stark du ein soziales Netzwerk nehmen und umkippen kannst.
Und das funktioniert. Ja, also das hätte ich halt, das fand ich wirklich einen erstaunlichen,
also eine erstaunliche Insight zu sehen, jo, das Ding kann jemand kaufen.
Jo, der kann das einfach umkippen und komplett verschieben, ja.
Und der kann da, weiß ich nicht, jedes Voice of Reason rauswerfen.
Also zum Beispiel, ich meine, mit dem durchschnittlichen Tweet hast du nicht
so viele Menschen erreicht, wie du Follower hast.
Aber vielleicht auf Dauer dann annähernd.
Kurz nachdem das Ding von Elon Musk übernommen wurde, habe ich kaum noch jemanden
erreicht. Ja, und das war halt, das waren halt dann einfach ein paar Änderungen
an, wie hier, wer hier wie verstärkt und verbreitet wird.
Und dann hast du natürlich eine Welt, wo jemand in, was hast du jetzt gesagt,
Russland sitzt und irgendwie MAGA-News twittert, ja, und dann eben...
Nicht unbedingt nur organisches Wachstum hat.
Oder zum Beispiel auch vielleicht früher oder später mal daran gescheitert wäre,
dass es bei dem alten Twitter zumindest das Ziel gab, so etwas irgendwie zu limitieren.
Da waren ja immer die Meldungen, ja, wir haben hier wieder eine russische Desinformationskampagne
entdeckt und mal 20.000 Accounts kurz dicht gemacht oder so.
Weil wir festgestellt haben, die kommen alle von der gleichen IP oder was auch immer.
Diese Bemühungen sind weg und ganz im Gegenteil, solange das jetzt Inhalte sind,
die Elon Musk gefallen, der ja nun mal ein politisches Ziel mit diesem Kauf
hatte, statt einem ökonomischen.
Das ist einfach ein irrer Effekt und dann ist er trotzdem noch blöd genug und
das ist ja das Spannende den Effekt kriegt einer hin der noch so blöd ist dann
zu sagen naja, zeig mal wo die ganzen Tweets herkommen oh shit, naja,
egal also der hat noch nicht mal also der zieht da irgendwie wieder eine Line
Keter, denkt sich irgendwas aus,
haut sich selber in den Hinterkopf und,
also so von dem Niveau und trotzdem kriegt er das Ding ja komplett zu drehen
und in irgendeiner Form relevant zu halten.
Ja.
Das sind wirklich Effekte, die enorm sind und die halt auch wirklich beängstigend sind.
Auf jeden Fall Scheißladen.
Kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Deswegen kaufen wir da nicht.
Deswegen haben jetzt auch alle Angst vor Social Media. Das ist nämlich schlecht für die Kinder.
Das ist ja, also Australien...
Hat festgestellt, dass mit diesem Social Media, das ist schlecht.
Schlecht für die Gesellschaft, schlecht für die geistige Stabilität von Kindern und Jugendlichen.
Und wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, Social Media unter 16 ist nicht.
Genauso wie Kippen und Alkohol.
Rauchen ist, glaube ich, ab 18 inzwischen.
Wo jetzt?
In Deutschland, in Australien weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube.
Kaufen darfst du hier auf jeden Fall im Kiosk nichts unter 18.
Kaufen oder saufen?
Meines Wissens sowohl als auch.
Okay. Also, als ich ein kleiner Junge war.
Ja, da hast du noch für Papa noch die Zigaretten Bier vom Späti geholt.
Und einen für mich.
Bring mir mal das und das mit. Ja, das war früher vollkommen normal.
Okay, also Australien entscheidet so unter 16 kein Social Media.
Du darfst keinen Account haben.
Jetzt kann man das von unterschiedlichen Seiten betrachten.
Erstmal gibt es natürlich jetzt so eine ganze Menge irgendwelcher, sagen wir mal,
wahrscheinlich zwischen 9 und 15-Jährigen, die sehr, sehr frustriert sind,
was jetzt mit ihren Accounts passiert,
die irgendwie diese sozialen Medien, über die sie mit ihren Freundinnen und
Freunden Kontakt halten,
die ihnen ja jetzt genommen werden,
die sehr frustriert sind über einen über das Fehlen dieser Möglichkeiten ähm,
Und die Frage ist, wird das wirklich jetzt dem Schutz dienen?
Also dieser Vergleich zum Beispiel mit Alkohol und Zigaretten.
Auch zum Beispiel, ich meine, es gibt Argumente dafür und dagegen,
dass das jetzt enorm gut ist, solche Sachen zu tun.
Zu verbieten und vor allem lange zu verbieten. Beispielsweise jetzt mit 16 Bier
zu erlauben, hat vielleicht auch den Effekt,
dass Kinder und Jugendliche wenigstens einen gesellschaftlich akzeptierten und
dadurch auch einen gewissermaßen gesellschaftlich kontrollierten Zugang zu diesen Nervengiften finden.
Ja, meine Erfahrungen in den USA,
wo das legale Alter zum Trinken 21 ist, sind,
dass die Leute da einen sehr viel schlechteren Zugang und Umgang mit diesen Rauschmitteln finden.
Dass da viel verbreiteter ist,
einen sehr unklugen, übertriebenen, schlechten Alkoholumgang zu finden,
als es jetzt vielleicht so ein deutsches,
bayerisches Kind, das so mit elf die Maß zum Weißbierfrühstück gereicht bekommt.
Viel besser sozial integriert. Ich will damit nur sagen.
Frühkünstiges Lernen heißt das.
Irgendwie ist halt dieses kann es halt auch eine.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das Verbot bis zu einem gewissen Alter unbedingt die
Mündigkeit im Umgang damit hebt.
Sinnvollerweise ist das in irgendeiner Weise kombiniert. Ja,
also wenn zum Beispiel Australien jetzt sagen würde, alles klar und wenn die
Kinder alle 14, 15 sind, dann klären wir die sehr darüber auf,
welche Mechanismen, wohin sie sich da begeben und dann führen wir sie da ran
und dann erklären wir ihnen den Umgang damit.
Das wäre so eine Position, wie man sagen könnte, so könnte eine Prohibition
mit Mündigmachung vielleicht helfen, die negativen Effekte zu verhindern.
Andererseits könnte man sich fragen, wieso verbietet man den Scheiß nicht einfach
ganz, wenn das für Leute unter 16 und ab 16 schädlich ist?
Warum machen wir es nicht wie mit Kokain, Heroin und allen anderen sehr sehr schädlichen Sachen,
wie heißt das was die Amis Fentanyl darf es zum Beispiel auch nicht ab 16 oder
18 haben wir einfach gesagt ist schlecht macht mehr Negatives als Positives
und macht ein paar Arschlöcher reich die sich nicht um uns kümmern,
und vielleicht könnte man auch einfach sagen verbieten wir es lieber ganz,
Dann haben wir das Problem nicht mehr. Wäre zum Beispiel so eine Position.
Die Sache mit dem Altersnachweis kommt aber auch dazu.
Jetzt müssen halt alle Australierinnen irgendwie, und zwar alle,
und vor allem die, die über 16 sind, irgendwie nachweisen, dass sie alt genug
sind, so einen Account zu bekommen.
Und auch das ist etwas, was potenziell eher diesen Netzwerken in die Hände spielt,
weil es sowas wie anonyme Accounts und so weiter jedenfalls erschwert.
Ja, die freuen sich natürlich auch über konkrete Altersangaben.
Das ist ja sehr gut für die Werbeauswertung.
Je mehr Informationen sie haben über die Leute, umso besser.
Es ist wirklich ein kontroverses Thema, aber ich hätte echt Sorge,
dass etwas dadurch, dass es verboten ist, gerade in dieser Altersgruppe,
oder dass es mit einem Alterslimit versehen wird,
gerade in dieser Altersgruppe eventuell an Attraktivität,
gewinnt und eventuell dazu führt, dass ein oder sagen wir, wenn das nicht irgendwie
begleitet wird, zu einem unmündigeren Umgang damit führt.
Ich halte das übrigens, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich das für ausgeschlossen halte.
Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, wurde uns in der Schule auch erklärt,
dass man vom Rauchen und vom Saufen stirbt und blöd wird und Sachen tut,
die einem nachher leid tun und was nicht alles.
Bei mir in der Schule war Fußball verboten. Man guckt, was jetzt mit mir passiert
ist. Jetzt stehe ich im Stadion. Das haben sie jetzt davon.
Ja, das haben sie davon.
Wieso war da Fußball verboten? Was war das denn für eine Schule?
Na, Waldorfschule.
Weil der rund war oder weil das toreckig war? Oder warum war Fußball verboten?
Also die Erklärung war nicht besonders gut, da haben sie immer irgendwas ominöses
von, ja das symbolisiert ja das Treten mit dem Fuß von sich gegeben,
eigentlich war ihnen das wahrscheinlich einfach nur zu prollig.
So Ausgrenzung und so weiter, so ein bisschen snobistisch.
Was habt ihr stattdessen gemacht?
Also Volleyball und lustigerweise auch Rugby, also es macht einfach vorne und hinten keinen Sinn.
Okay, naja, aber immerhin, ja, auch, also aber auch grundsätzlich,
nicht irgendwie bis zum gewissen Alter oder so.
Ist auf jeden Fall, kommt bei Jugendlichen nicht besonders gut an,
wenn man etwas, was sie durchaus schätzen und mit dem sie vielleicht auch umzugehen
wissen und dadurch ja auch erlernen, dass man es einfach verbietet.
Ich sage mal, das wird jetzt ganz interessant sein, zu sehen,
was das mal für Auswirkungen hat.
Nicht, dass ich das jetzt mir gewünscht habe, dass das passieren wird,
aber es ist natürlich jetzt auch interessant mal zu schauen,
was jetzt daraufhin passieren wird.
Es ist natürlich nachvollziehbar, dass wir in irgendeiner Form denken.
Uns Regeln überlegen müssen und es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt immer gesetzliche
Regeln sein, sondern auch so, sagen wir mal, gesellschaftliche Normen erarbeiten,
wie wir mit dieser digitalen Öffentlichkeit umgehen.
Weil du merkst ja auch, wir sind ja auch selbst gespalten.
Also auf der einen Seite sind es für uns Tools und wir hatten alle irgendwie
unsere schöne Twitter-Phase und wir hatten uns alle lieb und so weiter.
Und dann ist halt irgendwann einfach das Verbrechen eingezogen und die Politik
und auch die Kombination aus den beiden und hat es einfach für alle schlimmer gemacht.
Und jetzt haben wir einfach das Problem, dass das
eben so ein Aufstachelungstool geworden ist und eben auch mal wieder so eine
neue Quelle von Abhängigkeiten und viele Leute werden natürlich dadurch auch
einfach so ein bisschen in ihr Verderben gezogen. Aber eben bei Labi nicht alle.
Andere bauen sich da auch ein Business drauf auf, auch ein legitimes Business.
Ja, also ich denke, meine Überzeugung bleibt ja eher, es ist eigentlich das Geschäftsmodell.
Also ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, so einen Mastodon-Account sehe ich jetzt wenig Grundlage,
dass einer 16-jährigen Person nicht zutrauen oder zumuten zu können.
Während ich so ein TikTok, Instagram als Hardcore auf,
menschliche Abhängigkeit optimiertes Weltbeherrschungstool schon erkennen könnte,
naja, vielleicht wollen wir Kinder davor schützen.
Wie gesagt, ich würde einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen, warum eigentlich nur die Kinder?
Warum wir nur Frauen und Kinder schützen? Ja, was mit mir?
Ich hänge den ganzen Tag hier und zwei Peinen weg und kauf allen Scheiß und Tja.
Dir verbieten wir das jetzt auch Du schreibst auch nur Unsinn und so weiter.
Also es ist immer so ein Quatsch.
Also ich möchte mit meinen Freundinnen und Freunden.
Angeber bist du. Postest hier deine Vorträge und deine Meinung.
Postest überhaupt nichts mehr. Ja genau, meine Meinung jetzt kommt auch noch.
Auch das noch. Was kommt als nächstes? Podcast?
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall spannend, dass es jetzt mal jemand gemacht hat und
ehrlich gesagt würde ich mir wünschen, dass Australien das zu einem Erfolg,
ummünzt, aber dafür braucht es mehr als nur das Verbot.
Dafür braucht man jetzt, das braucht eine Begleitung.
Vielleicht eine Social Media Kampagne oder so.
Aber nicht auf X.
So, dann kommen wir nach Portugal. Es gibt mich doch eine gute Nachricht heute.
Es gibt eine gute Nachricht, eine richtig gute Nachricht.
Ja, also Portugal hat gesagt.
Warte mal, gute Nachricht.
Die gute Nachricht. Das war natürlich voll gelogen am Anfang.
Weltweit ist es ja für SicherheitsforscherInnen in vielen Ländern ein Risiko,
dass es Gesetze gibt, die das Hacking nicht erlauben.
Ähm,
die also quasi das Melden einer
Sicherheitslücke mit dem grundsätzlichen rechtlichen Risiko verbinden,
dass man sich damit selber de facto einer strafbaren Handlung bezichtigen muss.
Das ist weit mehr ein theoretisches Problem als ein praktisches,
das möchte ich immer wieder betonen.
Die meisten Menschen und Unternehmen sind schlau genug zu erkennen,
dass wenn eine Sicherheitsforscherin eine Schwachstelle meldet,
dass es sich dabei um eine freundliche,
kostenlose Dienstleistung handelt, für die man dankbar sein kann.
Aber es gibt eben ein rechtliches Risiko, dass mitunter auch mal die ein oder
andere Sicherheitsforscherin davon abhält, eine Meldung vorzunehmen.
Es ist, glaube ich, auch bekannt, dass wir als CCC bei so etwas gerne auch mal helfen.
Eine Meldung ordentlich vorzunehmen oder auch in einem besonders kritischen
Fall die Meldung dann für die Leute zu machen,
um quasi sicherzustellen, dass sollten die Unsouveränen darauf reagieren,
sie nicht wissen, gegen wen sie jetzt die Strafanzeige stellen sollen.
Sondern es wäre schön, hier diese rechtliche Grauzone und diesen Risikobereich
einfach wegzuschaffen.
Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, haben das jetzt auch mehrere Bundesregierungen
immer wieder angekündigt und versprochen, es dann leider nicht erfolgt,
weil man immer irgendwas anderes hatte.
Portugal hat jetzt eine Ausnahme formuliert,
in ihrem Cybercrime-Gesetz.
Und da schreiben sie, haben sie quasi einen Paragraphen, in dem sie sagen,
Handlungen, die nicht strafbar sind, aufgrund des öffentlichen Interesses an IT-Sicherheit.
Dann sagen sie,
wenn, also es gibt eine Ausnahme für Sicherheitsforscher, die mit dem Ziel und
dem alleinigen Ziel handeln, Schwachstellen zu identifizieren,
um somit zur Sicherheit beizutragen.
Und dafür haben sie viele Voraussetzungen, zum Beispiel ...
Du darfst ausschließlich darauf abzielen, nicht vom Forscher selbst verursachte
Schwachstellen zu identifizieren.
Du darfst jetzt nicht irgendwie auf der einen Seite eine machen,
die andere Seite melden.
Du darfst keinen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil
anstreben, der über eine übliche professionelle Vergütung hinausgeht.
Ich glaube, das geht einfach darauf zurück, dass man ja eben auch Bug-Bounties potenziell,
es gibt ja Unternehmen, die sagen, Wenn du uns eine Sicherheitslücke meldest,
haben wir ein Bug-Bounty-Programm und dann wäre es eben natürlich,
dass du auch mit der Meldung einen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil anstrebst in diesem Fall.
Ansonsten finde ich es eigentlich grundsätzlich, unser Ansatz beim CCC ist grundsätzlich,
dass wir niemals damit einen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil anstreben und auch niemandem helfen, der das tut.
Die Schwachstelle muss unverzüglich gemeldet werden und zwar dem Systeminhaber,
allen Verantwortlichen im Sinne des,
Datenschutzrechts und der CNCS, ich denke das ist die National Cyber,
hast du nicht gesehen, so ein BSI oder sowas,
die Handlungen, die du vollführst, müssen streng auf das Zuerkennung der Schwachstelle
erforderliche beschränkt sein, dürfen keine Dienste beeinträchtigen,
keine Daten verändern oder löschen und keinen Schaden verursachen.
Also so ein bisschen minimal invasiv. Nicht irgendwie sagen,
guck mal hier, da kann man ausmachen. Aus, hab ich mal gezeigt.
Keine unrechtmäßige Verarbeitung personenbezogener Daten im Sinne der DSGVO.
Klingt ein bisschen, da bin ich ein bisschen vorsichtig, weil ich nicht genau
weiß, wo die Schwelle ist, was jetzt Verarbeitung von Daten ist.
Zugreifen wird schon irgendwann mal nötig sein, weil die meisten Schwachstellen,
die gemeldet werden, sind eben,
Daten-Lags, ja, da weiß ich nicht genau, wie das dann im Detail ausformuliert
ist, aber es ist gleichermaßen auch klar, dass du jetzt nicht sagen kannst, alles klar,
ich nehme jetzt alle Daten und verarbeite die oder leake die und sage dann,
ich bin Sicherheitsvorscher oder so.
Gleichermaßen haben wir, glaube ich, vor zwei Folgen auch diskutiert,
dass da Leute einmal das komplette WhatsApp-Verzeichnis gedumpt haben und,
Ist das jetzt eine unrechenmäßige Verarbeitung personenbezogener Daten oder nicht?
Bin ich keine Fachperson? Irgendeine Form von Limitation muss da sein,
wie die genau jetzt formuliert ist, weiß ich nicht.
Der Forscher oder die Forscherin darf keine verbotenen Techniken einsetzen.
Da hört, und da nennen sie kein DOS, kein DDoS, kein Social Engineering,
kein Phishing, kein Passwortdiebstahl, keine vorsätzliche Datenveränderung,
Systembeschädigung oder den Einsatz von Schadsoftware.
Also ja, Phishing, Social Engineering, bei Passwortdiebstahl finde ich so eine
Sache, ich meine, wenn ich in einem Passwortleak ein funktionierendes Passwort finde und das melde,
weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das etwas Böses wäre, aber immerhin sind hier nicht
Hacker-Tools gelistet.
Und es geht jetzt quasi auch, also ich meine, wenn ich dich fische und dir dann
sage, übrigens, ich habe eine Schwachstelle gefunden, bei dir am Computer sitzt
ein Idiot, der jeden Link klickt, das ist jetzt keine Schwachstelle in dem Sinne.
Und wenn ich eine Schadsoftware bei dir installiere, also würde ich sagen,
ist schon das, was dort gelistet ist, bis eventuell auf Passwortdiebstahl.
Oder der aktive Passwortdiebstahl ist damit ja auch gemeint,
dann würde ich sagen, Das sind alles Sachen, die im Prinzip eine Sicherheitsforschung
potenziell auch einfach disqualifizieren.
Alle im Rahmen der Forschung erlangten Daten müssen vertraulich behandelt und
innerhalb von zehn Tagen nach Behebung der Schwachstelle gelöscht werden.
Okay, denke ich ist auch...
Ist jetzt eine Anforderung, der man gerecht werden kann.
Das führt nur so ein bisschen zu einer Beweislastumkehr oder zu einer Verpflichtung,
dass ich als Forscher entweder die
korrekte Behebung der Schwachstelle verifizieren muss oder die Aussage,
sie wäre behoben, mich jetzt zur Löschung aller Nachweise zwingt.
Das kann dann im Detail auch noch mal komplizierter werden.
Handlungen, die mit Zustimmung des Systeminhabers erfolgen, sind ebenfalls von
der Strafe ausgenommen.
Gefundene Schwachstellen müssen jedoch trotzdem der CNCS gemeldet werden.
Das klingt ein bisschen komisch, weil das klingt so ein bisschen,
dass sie da eigentlich letztendlich ihre Meldepflicht so ein bisschen zu dem nehmen,
um das zu hebeln und sagen, wir wollen als Staat das unbedingt wissen,
damit du straffrei bleibst.
Da gibt es natürlich auch so ein bisschen so ein Eigeninteresse.
Hat aber vielleicht auch den Vorteil, dass man sich dann quasi auch als Security-Expert absichert.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Das ist einer der Gründe,
warum wir bei vielen Meldungen beispielsweise das BSI oder auch die zuständige
Landes- oder Bundesdatenschutzbehörde mit informieren.
Um natürlich auch eine unabhängige Zeugin für die Meldung zu haben,
aber natürlich auch, um klarzumachen, welche Absichten wir verfolgen.
Und natürlich ehrlich gesagt auch bei manchen Fällen, um halt mal darauf hinzusteuern,
dass das nicht unter den Teppich gekehrt wird, was da gerne mal passiert ist.
Also, Portugal ist eine Option.
Hat auch gutes Wetter. Gutes Wetter.
Ungeeignet für eine russische Invasion.
Also vorerst.
Vorerst ungeeignet, ja.
Im Detail wird da immer was sein. Ich habe jetzt eine englische Übersetzung,
auf der ich das jetzt mache, von den portugiesischen Gesetzen und da gibt es
sicherlich natürlich noch eine Reihe an Fallstricken und Abhängigkeiten,
aber erstmal ist ja jeder Schritt in die richtige Richtung ein guter.
Wir erinnern uns, in Deutschland war auch mal, ich glaube Ende 24 mal einer
geplant, aber das ist dann irgendwo wieder, weiß ich nicht, da war auf einmal
wieder Stadtbild wichtiger oder so.
Nicht zugekommen. CNCS heißt übrigens Centro Nacional de Cyber Seguranza.
Ja, siehst du, das kannst du auch nichts hin überweisen.
Dann haben wir noch neue Polizeigesetze. in Berlin gibt es die Novelle,
des Allgemeinen Sicherheits- und Ordnungsgesetzes, das Asoc,
beschlossen mit der Mehrheit der Koalition, CDU und SPD und ein paar aus der
Opposition, in dem Fall AfD.
Aber die Koalition hat ja bereits eine Mehrheit, insofern lag es jetzt nicht an der AfD.
Was darf die Berliner Polizei jetzt? Klar, die darf deine IT-Systeme hacken,
aber wie soll sie das denn hacken?
Wenn du irgendwie auf der Friedrichstraße Fahrrad fährst, ah nee,
da fährt man jetzt wieder Auto, um deine Geräte zu hacken, darf sie verdeckt
in die Wohnung eindringen.
Sie dürfen quasi einbrechen in deine Wohnung.
Dann dürfen sie biometrischen Abgleich vornehmen von Gesichtern und Stimmen
mit öffentlich zugänglichen Daten aus dem Internet.
Videoüberwachung zum Beispiel in sozialen Netzwerken oder auf Fotoplattformen
suchen mit automatisierter Gesichtserkennung.
Das dürfen die.
Asoc. Bisschen Asoc-zial.
Ja.
Und in Sachsen, da haben sie jetzt auch eine neue Novelle vorgeschlagen,
die sagen halt so, ja pass auf,
wir würden gerne Leute, die beim Autofahren ihr Handy bedienen, mit Drohnen,
Erkennen und verfolgen. Dann Verhaltensscanner hätten wir gerne,
Parlantier, Datenanalyse, Live-Gesichtserkennung, Gesichtersuchmaschinen,
Staatstrojaner, das wollen wir alles benutzen.
Also Live-Gesichtserkennung wäre dann eben, in einer Videoüberwachung das quasi
live während des Geschehens zu machen. Das ist so China-Style.
Nicht im Nachhinein zu sagen, okay, wir gucken mal, hier ist etwas passiert,
sondern wir machen es einfach mal live.
Dann wollen sie Kennzeichenlesegeräte überall aufstellen.
Das ist ja so dieses, diese Dinger, die ja dann stehen dann irgendwo an,
besonders gern befahrenen Stellen, scannen jedes Kennzeichen und suchen dabei
nach Kennzeichen, die beispielsweise zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben sind,
speichern aber natürlich zur Sicherheit auch alles, was da dran vorbeifährt,
um nachher noch gucken zu können.
Ich frage mich auch ehrlich gesagt, was man, also in Sachsen ist ja so die Machtübergabe,
schon jetzt so am Horizont.
Was die sich dabei denken, ob die da jetzt schon mal alles nochmal vorbereiten
wollen, dass die AfD nicht so viel zu tun hat, wenn sie da an die Macht kommt.
Dass man schon mal quasi den Ladenbesen rein übergibt oder so.
Das macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, ja. Aber in Berlin ist auch nicht sehr viel anders.
Nee.
Ja, kein Bock darüber zu reden. Wir reden über 39C3.
Ach ja. Machen wir es uns mal ein bisschen einfach.
Der ist schon in elf Tagen.
Genau, geht bald los. Und selbst wenn ihr jetzt nicht dabei sein könnt,
weil ihr entweder keine Zeit habt oder kein Ticket habt, erwerben können.
Es ist ja alles auch live, also das Vortragsprogramm ist live verfolgbar.
Wird intensiv gestreamt und in der Regel auch sehr zeitnah als Aufzeichnung veröffentlicht.
Und ja, wir wollen mal einen Ausblick geben auf ein paar Talks,
die vielleicht eure Aufmerksamkeit verdient haben.
Genau, wir verlinken in den Shownotes
den Fahrplan, den Link zur Streaming-Plattform, die dann eben am 27.
Live übertragen wird. Das ist also dann so der Rohschnitt. Streaming.media.ccc.de
kann man dann schön laufen lassen nebenbei.
Und unter media.ccc.de werden dann eben die finalen, schönen,
aufbereiteten Videos mit Intro- und Outro-Video und so weiter vom VOG veröffentlicht.
Ich habe eine kleine Auswahl getroffen und zwar habe ich jetzt einfach primär
danach ausgesucht, Leute, die schon bei LNP waren,
die, ja, weil sonst ist es, ich meine, ich könnte jetzt den kompletten Polsock-Track
vorlesen, der letztendlich von Interesse ist.
Ich könnte den kompletten Security-Track vorlesen, für den unter anderem Kantorkel
und ich, der ja auch LNP-Gast regelmäßig ist,
verantwortlich waren für diese Auswahl vorlesen.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, ich gucke einfach mal, welche LNP-Track.
Gästinnen und Gäste könnt ihr auf den Bühnen sehen.
Ich hoffe, ich habe da jetzt alle gefunden. Gästinnen der letzten Zeit.
Es geht los. An Tag 1 direkt mit dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Stefan Pelzer und Philipp Ruch haben ja vor einem Jahr den Adenauer SRP Plus
als Baustelle noch auf dem 38C3 stehen gehabt.
Sehr gern gesehenes Hintergrundbild für Interviews.
Haben ihn jetzt ungefähr ein Jahr betrieben. Wir haben ja hier schon eine eigene
Sendung dazu gehabt, wo ich mit Stefan und Tassilo und Piet auf einer kleinen Busfahrt war.
Und sie werden jetzt so ein bisschen davon berichten und natürlich auch von
ihrer neuen Aktion, die uns auch wieder sehr schön ist, das Walter-Lübcke-Denkmal
vom Konrad-Adenauer-Haus,
das die CDU als schändlich,
betrachtet.
Kannst du dir auch... Ich bin gespannt, wer das Ding abreißt.
Ob es Friedrich Merz persönlich macht oder also das ist wirklich...
Oder unser Bürgermeister hier, von dem keiner weiß, wie er heißt.
Ah ja, der dann noch gedroht hat, dass jetzt irgendwie Kreuzberg irgendwas gestrichen kriegt.
Wunderschön, also diese Theaterstücke, die da...
Für die, die sie da den Anschluss machen, schreiben sich teilweise echt wie von selbst.
Das ist eine großartige Aktion, muss ich mal dazu sagen.
Also ich bin immer wieder völlig weggeblasen von den, also nicht nur von den
Ideen von dem ZPS, sondern auch von der Ausführung.
Also es ist einfach so irre gut.
Ich war auch vor Ort, hab mir das mal angeguckt und es ist einfach jetzt in
Spuckweite der CDU-Zentrale.
Da steht dieses Mahnmal und Blumengrenze und alles und die einzigen,
die sozusagen diesen engagierten, ermordeten,
von einem Terroristen, von einem rechtsradikalen Terroristen ermordeten Politiker,
der irgendwie halbwegs Rückgrat gezeigt hat, die einzigen, die das nicht feiern,
das ist wirklich so ekelhaft, ja?
So schlimm. ist so entlarvend und ja. Egal.
Es wird bestimmt wieder sehr unterhaltsam werden.
Dann kam die Bezirksbürgermeisterin, hat es eröffnet. Es war übrigens auch Michelle
Friedmann hat eine Rede gehalten zur Eröffnung.
Der ja aus der CDU ausgetreten ist. Lange da drin war. Ja, ein,
Es wäre so einfach gewesen, für die CDU zu sagen, oh Mensch,
ey, vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr uns das Ding da hinstellt.
Ja, müssen wir das nicht bezahlen.
Aber nein. Das kann man übrigens auch unterstützen, genau, bei der Gelegenheit.
Also der Solibus, den wir hier behandelt hatten als der Piet,
der ja an dem Tag, wo Stefan Tassilo und ich den Ausflug mit dem Adenauer gemacht
haben, gefahren ist, hatte ja dann auch noch den Solibus vorgestellt.
Die freuen sich über Spenden. Da kann man steuerlich begünstigt gemeinnützig
mit Spendenbescheinigungen hinspenden an das Zentrum übrigens auch.
Und die verschicken auch so Dankeschöne für bestimmte Spenden und die kommen erstaunlich schnell.
Also ich habe da auch eine kleine Spende hinterlassen und konnte die Weihnachtsgeschenke,
die ich als Dankeschön für diese Spende noch bekommen habe, kann ich jetzt verschenken.
Dann haben wir an Tag 1, 19.15 Uhr, Marc-Uwe Kling.
Der war ja schon mal vor einigen Jahren beim Kongress und hat dort aus Quality Land gelesen.
Diesmal liest er aus dem neuen Buch die Känguru-Rebellion das noch nicht veröffentlicht
ist das kommt erst noch und da werden wir am Ende noch zu einer kleinen Aktion aufrufen,
somit fällt er auch unter Leute die er aus LNP kennt, weil da werde ich wahrscheinlich dabei sein,
dann haben wir die ähm.
Bianca Kastel war ja auch bei uns zum Thema elektronische Patientenakte.
Sie hatte letztes Jahr zusammen mit Martin Tschirsich die dortigen eklatanten Verfehlungen erwähnt.
Auf dem Kongress präsentiert. Dann gab es ja diese Nachsorge,
so, ja, ja, wir haben das Problem jetzt behoben.
Wir werden irgendwie noch die drei Buchstaben aus der Straße oder so,
und dann machen wir einen Hash, und dann haben sie das über die elektronische
Ersatzbescheinigung wieder die Daten bekommen. Wir haben das ja alles behandelt hier mit Bianca.
Sie wird also quasi jetzt mal so ein bisschen den, was ist schlechte Karten-IT-Sicherheit
im Jahr 0, Der EPA für alle, also was ist jetzt in einem Jahr passiert,
wird sie da zusammenfassen.
Ich denke, das wird viele unserer Hörerinnen begeistern und interessieren.
Wir haben Khaleesi und Markus Reuter zum Thema der Chatkontrolle.
Markus Reuter hat das Thema ja enorm fleißig bei Netzpolitik.org behandelt.
Khaleesi als Vertreterin des CCC besonders auf der Edri-Ebene auch behandelt und begleitet.
Die beiden verfassen da ein Resümee, auch das für diejenigen,
die noch nicht genug von dem Thema haben. könnte eine Freude sein.
Ich glaube, eine der am meisten gefeierten Gäste letztes Jahr,
war das überhaupt letztes Jahr?
War ungefähr irgendwann im letzten Jahr, als Meredith bei uns war.
Die war ja auch Vortragende am 38 C3 und trägt dieses Jahr unter dem Titel AI
Agent AI Spy zusammen mit Utbaf vor.
Utbaf ist quasi der Vice President for Strategy and Global Affairs bei Signal.
Cooler Typ, hat auch schon mal vorgetragen auf dem Kongress und zwar zusammen
mit Thomas, war glaube ich sein erster Vortrag, Thomas Lohninger.
Das denke ich, dürfte viele interessieren.
Genau, es geht um AI-Agent, AI-Spy, also quasi den nächsten Schritt,
wie macht dieses Ganze und das
ist irgendwie etwas, was mir jetzt auch irgendwie erst so ein bisschen...
Zunehmend klar wird, also AI oder Machine Learning in diesem Ausmaß ist so die
erste technologische Revolution, die nicht,
es gibt sicherlich andere, oder ist seit langem eine der ersten technologischen
Revolutionen im Digitalbereich,
die nicht auch in den Händen der Userinnen und User liegt.
Ja, also weißt du, der Computer kam und wir alle konnten ihn programmieren.
Dann kam PHP, dann konnten wir alle Web 2.0 machen, dann Rails,
dann kam Blockchain, da konnten wir alle unser Geld gleichermaßen versenken.
Ja, das war für alle gleich.
Und dieses Machine Learning ist aber quasi durch die hohen Hardwarekosten,
okay, die werden sinken, aber auch durch den Datenbedarf, und die Daten sind
jetzt schon längst bei den Plattformen,
ist das jetzt so eine Technologie, die quasi auf einem schon vorhandenen Vorsprung
bestimmter Anbieter und Plattformen aufbaut und denen nochmal extra Schub gibt.
Und wo wir quasi schon in der Technologie selber stark im Hintertreffen sind,
die jetzt überhaupt noch zu demokratisieren, in den Händen der Nutzerinnen souverän
zu halten, Alternativen zu schaffen.
Anders als jetzt beispielsweise Blockchain oder andere Technologien,
die wir eben immer auch selber konnten,
Also mir so als Gedanke.
Ja, es stimmt schon. Man könnte auch argumentieren, wir hatten ja jetzt auch
die Diskussion um Cloudflare und solche Infrastrukturen im Internet,
wenn man sozusagen da überhaupt noch gleichberechtigt daran teilnehmen will,
ist man ja auch schon auf die Dienste von bestimmten Dienstleistern angewiesen,
wenn man zumindest gleichermaßen sicher sein möchte vor Angriffen etc.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Du kannst dich entscheiden, Cloudflare zu nutzen.
Du kannst aber auch deinen eigenen Web-Server machen.
Was du, die Frage ist, du kannst dich entscheiden, OpenAI oder Gemini zu nutzen.
Es wird aber ein bisschen schwierig, dein eigenes Chat-GPT zu Hause zu trainieren.
Also das meine ich mit dem...
Weil du den Zugriff auf die Daten so nicht hast, ja genau.
Meine Hoffnung ist, dass der Long-Term-Siegeszug den kleinen spezialisierten
Modellen und nicht den generalisierten gehört. Schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, eine Special Mention war, glaube ich, nicht in LNP. Aber freue ich mich
dann doch, dem würde ich dann doch empfehlen.
Ten Years of Dieselgate.
Vor zehn Jahren hat Felix Domke auf dem Kongress vorgetragen,
zu seiner Analyse des Steuergerätes von seinem VW Turan oder sowas.
Ja, der hat halt irgendwie, der hat halt die Firmware gedumpt und hat dann am
Ende wirklich quasi in dem Code die unterstellte Abschalteinrichtung nachgewiesen,
ja, der hat gesagt, hier so funktioniert die, das ist der auslösende Faktoren
durch Reverse Engineering,
also nicht in dem Code, sondern in dem Bytesalat, den er dann reversen muss.
Sondern hat dann eine sehr wichtige Rolle in der Aufklärung dieses Skandales
gespielt mit seinen technischen Erkenntnissen.
Das waren ganz hocheffiziente Verbrenner waren das.
Hoch...
Genau, er ist also, das ist einfach das, was er tut.
Das war, also er hat am 32C3 und am 33C3, also 2015 und 2016 zu diesen Themen,
vorgetragen und jetzt nach zehn Jahre später schaut er mal, was da noch so alles gab.
Und er hält den Vortrag zusammen mit Carsten Burger, den er da noch mit dazu
nimmt, der sich auch in diesem Bereich,
Viel bewegt hat er, also den nehmen wir noch mal so mit rein.
Und Nico Semsrott, ich weiß gar nicht, war Nico Semsrott schon mal in LMP?
Nein, auch nicht. Du kommst voll vom Weg ab.
Das lasse ich mir, ja, aber der wird auch noch mal, ja, er hält auch noch einen
kleinen Vortrag. Aber vielleicht korrigieren wir das mal.
Das geht jetzt auch nicht, dass wir immer nur mit seinem Bruder Vorlieb nehmen
müssen. Ich werde den Nico da noch mal rügen.
Aber ja, weißt du, um so eine Regel zu haben, muss man ja auch quasi ein paar Ausnahmen haben.
Thomas Lohninger, Tag 1, 21.45 Uhr,
Throwing your rights under the omnibus, how the EU's reform agenda threatens
to raise a decade of digital rights, zusammen mit Ralf Bendrath.
Ralf Bendrath war auch schon in der LMP. Und Ralf Bendrat ist vielen sicherlich
noch in Erinnerung als der Mitarbeiter von Jan-Philipp Albrecht,
der die DSGVO primär zusammen mit ihm oder für ihn ausgearbeitet hat.
Also Ralf und Thomas da.
Dann Klaus Landefeld. Ja, war auch schon in LMP.
Ich glaube, der war sogar bei LMP 200, wo wir Klaus hatten.
Das war eine der Bühnensendungen auf jeden Fall.
The Fight Against Data Retention and Boundless Access to Data.
Ja, wir wissen, ist Klaus da seit vielen, vielen Jahren im Bereich der Abwehr
von Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter aktiv.
Also auch da freuen wir uns auf einen Vortrag von Klaus.
Arne Semsrott, ja.
Regelmäßig bei uns zu Gast und natürlich auch dieses Jahr wieder dabei mit einem
Best of Informationsfreiheit.
Gegenmacht sind mehr Infos wirklich die Lösung.
Transparenz braucht Rechenschaft, aber wie sieht es eigentlich aus?
Da könnt ihr also einen wunderschönen Vortrag von Arno euch anschauen und jetzt
habe ich hier bei einem offenbar aus Versehen den Speaker-Link nur.
Kurz gucken, dass ich da, den habe ich jetzt vergessen.
Ah ja, Cory Doctorow.
Auch noch nicht in LMP, aber lange nicht mehr beim Kongress gewesen.
Ich glaube, der hatte die Keynote beim 27C3, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja.
Oder war das der 28C3?
Das war noch im BCC, ne? Glaube ich. Oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das war im BCC.
Dann könnte 28 oder 27.
The Coming War on General Computation 28C3,
Endlich mal wieder bei uns Er ist, denke ich Er hat viele Bücher geschrieben,
die alle sehr erfolgreich waren Über so Überwachungsdystopien Little Brother
und wie sie nicht alle heißen und er hat jetzt ein,
wunderschönes Buch Entschittification Why Everything Suddenly Got Worse and
What to Do About It, wo er quasi das Phänomen, das.
Plattformen und Services gut anfangen und dann scheiße gemacht werden und zwar
absichtlich, damit du Geld nachwirfst, sehr schön behandelt.
Also in dem Moment letztendlich, wo sie es sich erlauben können,
wo sie keine Konkurrenz mehr haben und dann halt nach und nach einfach immer
schlechter gemacht werden können, um immer mehr Geld rauszuzerren.
Ja, natürlich hat
er eine Trump-kritische Perspektive und möchte aber für das postamerikanische
Entschittification-resistant Internet eine,
wie nennt man das, reden.
Das dürfte glaube ich auch noch ganz interessant sein.
Viele, viele weitere sehr spannende Vorträge, natürlich insbesondere im Bereich
der Politik gibt es da zu sehen, im Stream,
in den Aufzeichnungen und wer nicht vor Ort ist, kann wenigstens diese Talks
dann in Ruhe zu Hause genießen.
Ich glaube in Chattification ist auch tatsächlich von ihm der Begriff Den hat
er geprägt und insofern ist es sehr angemessen, dass er dann da auch ein Buch drüber schreibt Ja.
Genau, das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die einzige,
Fortneuschöpfung die Cory Doctorow so über die Zeit schreibt,
gemacht hat. Ja, er ist ein, ja, der hat wirklich einen sehr guten Weitblick so,
was an Phänomenen kommt, also wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwie The Coming War on
General Computation, wo er ja im Prinzip sagt so, das nächste,
was passieren wird, ist, dass wir eben nicht mehr freie Computer haben.
Er hat 2011 erzählt, hat sich dann schon gezeigt, dass das so war.
Beziehungsweise jetzt ist es sichtbar, dass dieser Prozess begonnen hat.
Ja, genau. Also er behandelt diese Dinge gut, er hat eingängige Metaphern dafür,
die eben seinen sehr starken Nerd-Hintergrund,
seine technischen und gesellschaftlichen tiefen Kenntnisse und Einsichten gleichermaßen
für eine General Audience gut zugänglich und verständlich machen.
Schon eine sehr prägende Person, denke ich, der Internetfreiheitskultur.
Eben als Autor gibt es da ja auch eben andere Winkel, ähnlich wie Marc-Uwe Klingen ja in andere,
auf einer anderen Ebene diese gesellschaftlichen technischen Themen,
zugänglich macht mit Humor mit Quality Land 1, 2 und so das kulturell prägend ist für,
die, hoffentlich für die ganze Gesellschaft, nicht nur für uns.
Ja, ich denke, das sollte als Ausblick erst mal reichen.
Damit sind wir dann auch durch. Wir machen hier keine End-Jetification.
Ach doch, ich wollte sagen, die letzten paar Minuten kosten jetzt extra.
Die LNP ist kostenlos, aber mit Witzen kostet extra.
Schaffen wir noch eine Folge vorm Kongress?
Auf dem Kongress willst du ja nicht. Ich würde gewollt hätten.
Du wolltest mit mir eine Sendung zusammen machen.
Ja, warum nicht? Ich habe noch ein paar Termine frei.
Da müssen wir nochmal drüber reden. Ja, also wir haben noch einen Termin im
Kalender vor dem Kongress.
Gut, dann nutzen wir den. Ich habe ihn gerade gefunden.
Und zum Thema, dann können wir uns auch dazu äußern, ob wir da auf dem Kongress
noch was machen. Ich sehe das ja noch nicht so ganz.
Mal schauen.
Alright, dann seid ihr jetzt entlassen und wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche.
Wird es keinen Spendenaufruf machen?
Hab ich doch schon mal gemacht. In der letzten Folge ja, also ich meine,
man könnte natürlich jetzt hier auch mit der In-Gertification anfangen und das permanent,
immer wieder betonen, so, aber bis dann irgendwann steht.
Tim Pridlaw ist ein Podcast-Bettler.
Naja, also ich meine, es ist,
Es ist mir, ganz ehrlich, also mir ist es ein Anliegen, nicht alle permanent zu nerven.
Ich dachte für andere jetzt, ich habe ja jetzt hier gerade für Solibus,
für ZPS, ich dachte nicht für dich.
Sondern für dich, oder was?
Ja, dann hätten wir, das wäre so uneigennützig.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir machen Schluss, oder?
Ja, das war's. Leute, bis bald.
Tschüss, schau, schau.